je me suis promené pendant des années à
travers le monde pour enseigner et je
vais continuer j'avais encore besoin la
d'enseigner mais comment le faire sans
se déplacer mais pas en utilisant les
méthodes conventionnelles en envoyant
des fichiers en gardant une vidéo
comment pourrait-on être beaucoup plus
présent avec le pointeur expliquer par
exemple que ceux-ci l'oreillette gauche
c'est l'oreille droite ne vendre que le
droit le ventricule gauche d'ici de ton
côté tu cliques sur le pointeur toi
aussi ton pointant peut apparaître dans
les cas alors ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va se concentrer sur l'un d'eux me
gardien et maintenant on va faire un peu
d'assistance alors si je te demande
d'aller mettre exactement par dessus la
mienne
tu peux donc avec ton doigt parfait et
maintenant je vais déplacer ma main et
tu peux me suivre le compte au fait bien
on va remonter un peu plus haut un
monsieur parfois on arrête là et ont des
seins trop doucement
finalement tu vois ici on voit la partie
triangulaire ici de la paix du coeur va
mettre ton exactement par dessus où je
suis très bien je suis capable avec ma
vraiment jeu pour avoir les outils dans
les mains c'est vraiment cette
collaboration l'eau augmenté mais
appliquée dans un espace intégré